hello again friends you're about to do
lesson five in the course so let's just
Jump Right
[Music]
In in our last lesson we looked at
organizing your thoughts clearly in
lesson five we'll look at effective
pauses concise tip number five is pause
to add emphasis and this really is a
conciseness tip however it's going to
make you sound much more clear and
certainly much more confident pauses in
the wrong places can make you sound long
winded pauses in the right place make
you sound clear concise and good pauses
emphasize your points and add a
confident Cadence it gives your speech a
rhythm or a Tempo that those
professional speakers and those leaders
have pauses are really like a secret
weapon in communication Ralph Richardson
a well-known actor on the stage and
screen from years ago said the most
precious thing in speech are pauses and
I could not agree more Strat number one
pause at the end of sentences that's
where your pauses belong it makes you
sound more confident it lets listeners
accept and remember your message during
that pause they get to process it for
just a moment and it gives you a natural
stopping place to end your talking turn
that's one of the goals of being a
concise and clear and confident
Communicator is you make your point and
as we said in an earlier lesson then you
zip it and it allows you to have a back
and forth or a dialogue with with other
people because the pause gives them a
place to jump in so let's listen to
where the pauses are here we have a few
items to cover today we'll look at our
social media campaign we'll look at our
overall growth and AR will take
suggestions about changes to the website
now these pauses are in the right place
they're where the punctuation is at the
end of the nice concise sentences these
are good examples of concise sentences
from an earlier lesson and if we were to
VIs visualiz this it looks a little bit
more like bullets in a list where the
pause comes right at the end of that
bulleted item and then you go on to the
next item these are like headlines that
we talked about in an earlier lesson or
even they're not funny but the length of
a punch line for a joke and that's where
the pauses
belong pauses at the end literally
punctuate your statements for listeners
it helps them separate the ideas because
you have with the sound of your voice
separated your ideas
you should only pause for about one
second just long enough to say the word
pause in your head sometimes people
pause for two or three or more sentences
to add that dramatic feel I don't think
that's necessary in most cases just long
enough to say the word pause or period
in your
head strategy number two avoid midth
thought pauses pauses in the middle of
your statements really make it drag and
it'll sound labored and long-winded even
if you're not using a lot of words
so let's listen to what it sounds like
when the pauses are in the wrong place
we have a few items to cover today we'll
look at our social media campaign we'll
look at our overall growth and Aaron
will take suggestions about changes to
the
website so it doesn't sound right it
sounds like we're hanging we're waiting
for that next moment that just oh finish
your thought and you may have listened
to people in conversation where they
pause and the middle and it can take an
ordinary sentence and make it really
sound extra long so we want to pause in
the right places strategy three is to
pause to separate key ideas when we're
for example giving a road map to set up
a meeting or a presentation we want to
pause between items in that meeting or
presentation and anytime you're listing
items two or three or four items you
want to pause where the commas are so
here's a sentence 80s rock is the best
because it has loud drums crunchy
guitars and soaring vocals so we're
pausing where we see the punctuation
would naturally be and it gives it that
nice confident sound where the ideas are
separated some people by the way would
say screeching vocals instead of soaring
vocals but I was trying to be kind
because I'm a big fan of 80s rock so
pause in the right place for clarity and
emphasis our takeaway strategies are to
pause at the end of sentences avoid
midth thought pauses that give it that
draggy sound and to pause to separate
ideas in a list especially things like a
preview statement in a presentation or
when you're setting up a meeting your
task is to practice pausing and all your
communication to add that Clarity in the
next few days it's also going to sound
make it sound much more confident and
much more concise for your listeners up
next we are going to work on avoiding
fillers and I look forward to seeing you
in that
lesson okay